hola
[Música]
[Aplausos]
no no
[Música]
tenemos que hablar no se preocupen esto
va muy en serio
tenemos que hablar sobre la verdad
quienes de aquí han jugado yo nunca
nunca
para todos los que no han jugado yo
nunca nunca les explico rapidísimo
tienes que hacer una pregunta incómoda
que la respuesta sea sí o no y si
respondes con un sin levantar la mano
vamos a hacer primero una prueba yo
nunca nunca he visto un télex en vivo
todos aquí han visto un kleenex arriba
las manos
ahora vamos a empezar en serio yo nunca
nunca he utilizado el coche sabiendo que
hay contingencias
todos los que sí lo hayan hecho levantan
la mano
yo nunca nunca
he insultado a alguien o lo he llamado
en tal por cual
[Música]
yo nunca nunca he construido mi
felicidad sobre la tristeza y el
sufrimiento de otros
para todos aquellos que no levantaron la
mano en la última pregunta les quiero
preguntar acaso nunca se pusieron
felices cuando el maestro faltaba clases
cuando se informaba
acaso no se pusieron felices cuando
tenían un pedazo de carne en su mesa
había precios bajos en su tienda
favorita y esa ropa probablemente estaba
hecha por trabajo forzado
ahora les quiero preguntar a todos
ustedes por qué nos convierte por qué
nos comportamos así nos comportamos así
porque se nos olvidó que lo que le da
significado y sentido esta vida
no es recolectar bonitos azules ni ser
juanas verdes ni diego o riberas morados
se nos olvidó que no hay que recibir
sino también que hay que dar se nos
olvidó que todos nacimos en el planeta
tierra y que todos somos de la misma
especie se nos olvidó que a pesar de que
tenemos la gran capacidad de construir
compañías industriales o instituciones
gubernamentales no somos dueños de
ningún territorio de ninguna persona y
mucho menos de estos pensamientos
ahora todos estos constructos sociales
como el dinero los estereotipos la
posesión el material
nos estamos enfocando en todo esto que
son los causantes de todos los problemas
mundiales hipotéticamente digamos que se
dejan de hacer humanos
la cantidad que hay en nuestro planeta
es de 7.500 millones de personas ahora
empecemos a hacer mates 7500
millones de personas menos las personas
que mueren en la guerra menos las
personas
que mueren por hambre
menos las personas que mueren por la
contaminación
menos las personas que mueren por
enfermedades
menos las personas que mueren en
feminicidios y si vemos esto a lo largo
de un año esta es la cifra de personas
que moría por no tener las necesidades
más las necesidades básicas
este es nuestro resultado en la mitad de
la población moriría
claramente está no se pondría triste
porque tendría que renunciar porque el
trabajo
lo está haciendo ya el nombre propio
hoy en día nos vemos algo así estamos
tan concentrados en ganar una gran
cantidad de dinero en cumplir con los
estereotipos y en tratar de ser dueños
del mundo que estamos normalizando
estos constructos sociales y esta forma
de actuar del humano es una forma
alarmante de actuar del humano y creo
que no sé si ustedes se les hará a
alarmante pero creen que en verdad es
correcto vivir en un ambiente donde hay
constante odio a sí mismo y a los demás
esta es una imagen que encontré
construyan el muro en mi casa odio a
todos al principio les podría aparecer
totalmente cómico pero después si
reflexionamos y nos vamos más allá nos
damos cuenta que esta situación está
para abrir los ojos está para
reflexionar y hacer algo al respecto
alexander von humboldt no soft no sólo
fue
un explorador de la naturaleza sino
también fue un defensor de los derechos
humanos
él creía que todos a pesar de sus
diferencias eran parte de una gran parte
de un todo
por eso y él quería al igual que el
humano debería de buscar su felicidad y
su paz interna en algo que no se le
pudiera quitar o ser arrebatado por eso
quiero que todos hagan este experimento
conmigo saquen sus lentes ya los tienen
ahora pónganse los
estos lentes los pueden con encontrar
donde quieran son 24/7 los pueden
encontrar donde quieran son gratis y
además tienen algo que se llaman los
rayos x para detectar los corazones de
alcachofa pero que son los corazones de
alcachofa los corazones de alcachofa son
todos esos corazones con el coraje de
ser la definición de coraje es mostrar
de quién eres
contar tu historia con todo tu corazón
ahora los corazones de alcachofa son
todos esos corazones sin capas sin
estereotipos sin etiquetas sin
constructos sociales los corazones de
alcachofas son simplemente ellos creo
que es necesario
les voy a contar una historia personal
yo toda mi infancia fue conocida como
alegría a la niña que siempre estaba
feliz y a través del tiempo empecé a
reflexionar sobre todos estos
constructos sociales estos problemas
mundiales y caí en una depresión este
año al principio viendo la vida positiva
y después de pensar entonces que estos
constructos sociales como el dinero los
estereotipos y también pensar de él
porque en un mundo de donde vivimos con
7.500 personas de pérez
con 7500
millones de personas existe el concepto
de soledad
acabe algo así
no salía de un cuarto me quedaba pensar
y pensar y después de darle vuelta a
todo esto me di cuenta que era hora de
dejarme de quejar dejar desde el primer
mes y salir adelante y empezar a actuar
necesitamos cambiar la actitud y la
perspectiva en la que nos vemos a
nosotros mismos y el que vemos a los
demás para así poder hacer un cambio en
este mundo
necesito no esperen necesitamos todos
nosotros actuar como si estuviéramos en
una crisis no sólo una crisis física
como el cambio climático sino también
una crisis emocional necesito que
actuemos como si nos estuviéramos
derrumbando porque lo estamos haciendo
necesito que abramos los ojos y
cosechamos corazones de alcachofa para
así sembrar un cambio en este mundo
yo siempre siempre tendrá el coraje de
ser humano yo nunca nunca seré el poder
el dinero y el material que tengo
[Aplausos]